Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number,
that number is two, one nine two. David
P. Here's a little xenophobia to kick off
the week for us. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Not sure if you can put this on
the show, but I've see you people who are from
this country to shut the fuck up, right?
Speaker 1: If you are not from the U.S.,
you have no right to speak, but it only applies to
first generation because just about everybody here
was born to someone who was either born
elsewhere or they were born to someone
who was born elsewhere. You get the point. But I
guess you have to be born here to have opinions
Speaker 4: in this story.
Go back to your own country
Speaker 5: and shut your mouth. You
don't know what is going on in America,
and you never will understand it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, by the way, that's that's a
Rhode Island accent, that's not a Boston accent,
just so people know we get a lot of hate from
Rhode Island. There's really quite a xenophobic
right wing enclave in Rhode Island. It's probably
would be an interesting thing to study. But this
is a very old idea. You know, if you're not.
There was a point where during the Iraq War, they
would say, if you haven't served, you can't have
an opinion about whether we should be in Iraq,
really, it doesn't make a lot of sense. It's a
really weird thing to say. But you know, I've
been here since age five, and I know far more
about what's going on here than than in any other
country. We've got a great bonus show for you
today. Sign up at Join Packman dot com to get
Unidentified: instant access to the bunker.